le lycée carnot 10 hectares au coeur de
la ville dédiée à l'enseignement
secondaire depuis
1893 sans surprise l'espace y est
organisée de façon militaire avec une
cour d'honneur où on levait les couleurs
chaque matin et un plan divisée en
quartiers comme on le ferait dans une
caserne un exemple typique
d'établissement de la troisième
république dans une société qui n'a pas
oublié que c'est le général bonaparte
qui a inventé les lycées et qui se
prépare à affronter de nouveaux
soubresauts de l'histoire nous sommes en
1893 exactement entre la guerre de 70
est la guerre de 14 et ses générations
la avait
2,2 à venir si je veux dire d'être
l'élite de la nation
et puis être surtout l'encadrement de
l'armée qui ramènerait dans les bras de
la france l'alsace et la lorraine qui
était nous avaient été arrachées en 1805
c'est le dix jeunes et arthur chaude ou
et qui a remporté le concours
d'architecturé sa feuille de route bâtir
à l'époque le seul lycée du département
capable d'accueillir 900 élèves en
majorité interne des inscriptions
rappelle qu'il lui a fallu imaginer bien
plus que des salles de classe c'est
aussi l'époque de l' architecture
métallique triomphante la tour eiffel a
été érigée quatre ans plus tôt dans les
architectures au quotidien c'est j'ose
dire on va utiliser le matériau alors
ici à carnot et bien n'y échappe pas on
a un lycée qui à structure métallique ça
se fait c'est pas évident quand on le
regarde mais c'est un peu comme dans les
gares parisiennes voyez les façades
c'est en pierre c'est du pit derrière un
vous avez une architecture métallique
fantastique au début l'établissement
n'avait pas de nom on le nommer le
nouveau lycée de dijon il sera baptisé à
la suite de l'assassinât du président
sadi carnot mais c'est bien toute la
famille carnot qui est ainsi honoré
une grande famille côte-d'orienne qui a
rendu à la france dé des services c'est
j'ose dire d'un domaine de la séance
dans le domaine de la politique dans le
domaine militaire en près de cent trente
ans de nombreuses personnalités alors
élèves ont arpenté ces galeries
le prix nobel de médecine roger
guillemin le résistant raymond aubrac ou
encore le comédien jean pierre marielle
l'histoire est ici partout dans ces
photos de la guerre de 14-18 où on
découvre le lycée transformé en hôpital
militaire ou encore dans cette
collection d'instruments de physique qui
comprend sept machines générant de
l'électricité statique le fonctionnent
encore
% à 8 % huîtres on a fait une affaire
nationale et encore cent vingt ans plus
tard en parfait état
on a l'impression un peu de faire partie
d'un lycée qui a une qui a une âme
réellement on se surprend dès fois
admirer encore les bâtiments même au
bout de 30 ans de carrière dans ce lycée
je suis toujours admiratif d'un d'une
petite lumière qui apparaît sur sur un
bâtiment de petits détails
d'architecturé
de choses comme ça un lieu qui ne
demande qu'à perpétuer sa riche histoire
et pour cela faisons confiance aux 2500
élèves accueillis chaque année